a mudslide on your mansion the butler
has Ebola and there's a Botox shortage
what's the 1% to do when the world they
might have helped destroy finally
crumbles get the best doomsday survival
kit money can buy if you're an extra
special human billionaire you might want
to consider writing out Armageddon in a
missile silo
no really meet the survival condo which
puts the cash in cash test Rafi it's a
hundred and seventy four foot deep
luxury bunker built in a former nuclear
missile silo survival condos website
says when anything is possible
preparation is peace of mind and
features an image of a destroyed US
Capitol building which give in
Congress's recent track record appears
to be an improvement condos here will
run you from one and a half to four and
a half million dollars small price to
pay to be insulated from the apocalypse
because in survival condo no one can
hear the poor scream how do you get
there st. Louis residents are willing to
make the 7 plus hour drive should a
catastrophe happen
seven hours I can't outdrive zombies for
seven hours plus I gotta get to say
Louis first and then I got to make it
past the Ferguson police and they're a
little shootie the bunker also features
a hydroponic garden movie theater and a
dog park and if worse comes to worse
happy dogs make yummy dogs why spend
money trying to save this planet when
you can spend the same amount to ditch
it am a is mars bitches that's what
Tesla CEO and real-life
Tony Stark Elon Musk believes he's
trying to get to Mars because he says
life should have a backup like a hard
drive that a so-called genius can
actually recover what do you mean it's
gone what's that on everything in a
reddit asked me anything musk announced
there would be an announcement for his
Mars announcement sometime this year
it's like a billionaire techie baby
shower what we already know is that he
plans to set up a colony on the Red
Planet and that his company SpaceX will
be the ones to take him there
according to SpaceX's third-party
providers spacesuits will need to be
quote badass just like their successful
Kickstarter campaign
thank you for your Kickstarter support
all right
must says the suit should be functional
but look aesthetically pleasing he has
always been so good at putting form
before function
all right so turdy the modern-day Noah
says the hardest part of the exodus from
Earth will be getting to the promised
land I would like to die on Mars just
not on impact and I would like a Tesla
just not one that makes me look like a
douche bag you can't have everything
Elon finally there's the freedom ship
which could help you survive a coming
global warming water world without Kevin
Costner the 11 billion dollar 3 million
ton steel Kraken is the biggest not yet
built please call the number on your
screen to invest maritime vessel in the
history of the world it'll be a floating
city able to house 60,000 people
shopping malls a subway system hospitals
even jet runways it's an aircraft
carrier for the whole family
even though units run up to 5 million
dollars a pop marketing chief insists
its intended not to be an elitist
community
he says it's supposed to emulate a
normal city but when I asked him about
homeless people he said a homeless
person
no that is not our intent what about
street performers street performers
absolutely but freedom ship isn't about
escaping the apocalypse but it also
isn't not about escaping it if you're
talking I don't know worldwide a bola or
something like that could this be a safe
haven yes it could be our primary
intentions it would be a global commerce
Center it's set to be the biggest
floating tax haven next to Jeff Bezos
with water wings
let's see a fantastically ostentatious
boat that claims to be the biggest ever
built accessible only to the super-rich
what could go wrong strange cuz even
though they're trying to escape global
disaster perhaps the biggest pandemic on
earth are billionaires themselves for
the rest of us without a fancy escape
pod I think we'll do just fine without
them oh watermelon